it's time for screen junkies movie
fights this episode is presented by
gamestop get the hottest t-shirts hats
and more only at Gamestop power to the
players what's going on everybody
welcome to movie fights it's a very
spooky Halloween edition
shout out salination hashtag go
hooligans hashtag Percival in the house
where my owls at yes we do have a very
special spooky Halloween horror edition
and we have some creepy crawly fighters
to fight it out but they're also pretty
cool nice people like not really creepy
or crawly at all first up she's neither
creepy nor crawley she's actually pretty
awesome she's uh from DC daily and you
see her all over the internet and she is
a horror movie aficionado welcome back
to the party Clark wolf thank you for
having me I'm so happy to be here I've
actually never I've judged this spooky
movie fights in the past
aha and I have never competed in it so I
am actually very excited to do this
today well we'll see if you can emerge
standing at the ends like the
protagonist and horror movie oh this guy
just made his debut appearance on the
debut deathmatch and now he's here to
slay the competition and you know from
hyper RPG and all over the place is
super funny knowledgeable individual
Cameron Rice
I made a mistake in wearing a sweater
under but it's the right sweater
popularized by Jackie Earle Haley
oh yeah yeah both yeah had a bad history
with kids the children and Freddy
Krueger popularized by Robert Englund
similar taste in fashion similar taste
in fall apparel and let's welcome back
you know her from the Schmo down and
she's just a delight and you know her
from it guest oh yeah many places on the
internet hyper RPG welcome back the
macabre referred to as macabre before
but I will take it I'm just saying it
because it's a Halloween thing kind of
us so right now where my characters have
vampire okay and you guys are gonna be
competing we're gonna be judging myself
and we got the damn cam happening first
off let me welcome our fact checker the
devilish Dan Merle wait a little bit
alliteration that's good I like like
your a Freddy vs. Jason shirts and two
shirt they're nice nice yes 8-bit
graphics hell yeah and we usually have
our our other Dan from the Dan camp
Daniel Radford but she is doing
something spooky or maybe just as a fire
fire commitment today this this woman
killed it on the debut death match
please welcome the villainous Vanessa
Goren so Vanessa dan and I will be
chiming in with our votes for each
question on who took that round but you
are the voice of the people do you want
to enlighten us as to how that works
yeah I've been monitoring and monitoring
a Twitter the second we started it just
exploded with all memes I've never seen
so many in one place but I'll also be
announcing the majority vote on Twitter
grace right and if you're watching at
home if you want to play along of course
play and follow on that Twitter hashtag
movie fights live but also there will be
in the corner of your YouTube screen a
poll that poll will not be live until
all the contestants have answers so
people don't start voting before they
hear the initial arguments but it'll be
in the upper right hand corner of your
screen if you don't see it at home just
refresh the page check your settings
make sure that annotations are on you
can vote and Vanessa a 1/3 of the vote
will be your voice so the audience vote
will count for one third of the vote
house and of course myself and I hope
you enjoy the show it's gonna be fun
heck yeah and you know before I get to
the game you know I gave a shout out to
that pretty sick Freddy vs. Jason sure I
want to just thank our sponsor Game Stop
for sponsoring this horror and Halloween
themed episode of movie fights we want
you to head on over to gamestop for all
of your collectible needs including
these spooky soft line tees that Dan and
I are rocking
yeah I gotta say this this t-shirt it's
it's pretty spooky and like awesome for
the season but it's comfy to seasonal
and climate appropriate big boxy or
Scratchy much much more GameStop go
check it out so this is a best-of-seven
game first person to four points wins
their three regular round questions then
the two top players after those three
questions head to the speed round and
the speed round
you know anything can happen so I'm
gonna be down 300 and then mount a
massive comeback in the speed round and
take the whole darn thing so let's jump
into the phone or you fun let's jump
into the club
yes uh are you guys ready to rock let's
do it JT dropped that sick ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thor okay so getting right
down to business with some ooh like this
question horror-themed here we go what
is the best horror movie of the 21st
century
the best horror movie of the 21st
century oh boy
so many I can think of let's start with
quite well fo all right let's do it
so um this is a this this is a
no-brainer to me I and I see a lot of
horror movies for better and for worse
and in you know looked horror as a very
specific genre in that taste
I think factors in a lot when you're
talking especially when you're talking
about best right and quality and
favorite and all of that to me the movie
that checks all of the boxes is James
wands the conjuring so James Wan I could
I could sing his praises for days I
think that he has a potential to be the
next Steven Spielberg and and this is
the movie that really pushed it over the
edge for me now yes as a horror fan I
love saw and I even love dead silence to
be honest with you and I love the
insidious franchise but the conjuring is
a real movie I think that it's actually
a great movie not just a great horror
movie the characters we love they are
relatable you Vera Farmiga and Patrick
Wilson have an incredible chemistry and
you know unlike a lot of horror movies
they really really invest in the
relationships but not only are vera and
patrick gray the the parent family is
also we love them and and at the end of
the day this is a movie about mothers
and with some sick-ass scares because i
would argue that this is the place where
james really upped his game in terms of
the in terms of the james wah
a conic james wan horror sequence so to
me in terms of in addition to being
critically successful commercially
successful and clearly spawned an
incredible franchise it's it's
undeniable
an excellent film all right Clark an
opening salvo for the conjuring Cameron
I'm going with David robert michels it
follows the movie that everyone called
the STD horror film that's the easy way
to describe its much like never Elm
Street it's very easy to just describe
it as the nightmare film Bowen makes a
film like nightmare
work is what Wes Craven was also playing
with 80s divorced children how you can
feel abandoned by your parents and what
I love about it follows is it's got some
great scares the cast is phenomenal they
do great work it's very subtle
the score is great but the reading on it
follows that I really appreciate is and
the movie makes it very clear this is
not the character losing their virginity
that's not what happens they've already
had sex those things have already
happened it's a movie about realizing
your mortality and that death is always
gonna be coming for you and that the
character now is at that age where you
realize oh I'm not gonna live forever
and that the younger characters around
her don't see it don't understand what
she's talking about because they're all
in highschool they still have that thing
about them and that's the second nice
little layer of the movie that's a good
part of the Oreo but for me what really
makes it work as well is the way the
scares are set up the way that it
doesn't it doesn't seem to be set in any
kind of time which I love that there's
nothing that's gonna date the movie in a
year
there's no call out to things there's
older cars but people have modern
seemingly modern devices that don't
actually exist so then we're never gonna
have that thing and we've all seen it if
you go to any kind of horror movie
revival if you go see the thing the
minute the chess game comes up half the
audience starts tittering because it's
all technology the movie bypasses all of
that by just telling a great simple
story very very effectively all right
Cameron hitting us with it follows Emma
Fife all right well I am going with
another fantastic horror movie that you
can watch on Netflix because all of the
movies were arguing for today are on
there and you should watch them but I am
going with the 2016 film directed by Yun
Seong ho train to Busan
it is a Korean film and it what it does
extremely well is it's not attempting to
reinvent the wheel it is taking a genre
that we're all very familiar with and
that in theory has been well not even in
theory in actuality has been overdone
quite a lot which is the zombie film and
just not even necessarily giving a fresh
take on it so much is just showing that
genre at its best and that is mostly
done through the exploration of the
themes that zombie films exemplify which
in the case of this movie is very much
about corporate greed and class systems
and what happens and how does humanity
react when society collapses essentially
and and again my feeling about any good
horror film is that it either needs to
have characters that you really really
care about so that you really feel it
when they die or characters that you'll
really really hate and you're really
happy when they meet their untimely
demise and this film absolutely has both
of those exemplified in a really really
interesting and nuanced character arc on
the part of the main character who's
played by Gong Yoo and then the parallel
with him and the evil CEO character who
literally throws people under trains in
this case not buses in order to elevate
his own status and thinks only of
himself so there is this real journey in
there of somebody going from you know
under basically being totally
self-centered and then in the face of
society completely falling apart growing
into a person who actually genuinely
cares alright three interesting opening
arguments fight it out you guys
so I struggle a little bit with it
follows which I really do like as a film
but I think that one of the things that
Clark and I touched a little bit upon in
both of our arguments is this whole idea
of feeling a real connection to the
characters and going on this journey
with that which isn't to say that it's
not present in it follows but I not as
emotionally invested in the characters
I would go as far as to say that it is
not present in it father I you know of
all of these I would argue like my
personal opinion is I don't like it
follows thanks that's my personal
opinion but this is the only one that
out of these three that is divisive
critically device sure it's awesome the
only it's also the only one that didn't
quite breakthrough I think that after
the festival circuit they wanted it to
break through I know as a horror fan I
saw this push and the die-hard fans
really went for it but at the end of the
day it didn't connect with wide
audiences I'm not saying that that is
it's it's the only criteria for best but
I do think that in order for something
to be the best people have to like it
I would agree I think generally a lot of
people did like it the reasons I have
often found people don't like it is
those lovely things about logic and why
didn't the characters got on a plane and
why do this because there wouldn't be a
movie that's stupid to me I love the
country all these movies great Kandra is
great until the last 20 minutes turn
into a really boring Exorcist remake
very quickly and James Wan I love James
Wong as a director I think design wise
his horror movies he has never come up
with a character that he didn't think
could be a Todd McFarlane toy a year
later from puppet in dead silence jigsaw
the way the ghosts look and again I love
his stuff but I was doing a rematch of
the shining recently and there's the
hallway scene and Danny sees the two
girls closes his eyes the girls are gone
and you leave the scene it's this creepy
scene and James wants films have been
very guilty of if he made the shining
like the anyone designs girls won't be
there the camera will go like this and
someone go with a CGI now you're talking
about the conjuring franchise which are
not directed by James Wan you're talking
about the actual conjuring I don't push
back on the the last 20 minutes because
upon rewatch that is the moment where I
think it really drives home that this is
a movie about mothers this is that we
are talking about love between mother
and child and the fight for that
see it laying the groundwork throughout
the whole thing Vera Farmiga and her
relationship with her daughter and
ultimately having to be forced out of
the house and where the daughter is in
peril but with Lily taylor's character
what we see in those final scenes are a
mother truly fighting another evil
mother which is what Bathsheba is sure
for the sanctity of her family to me it
gives me chills every time I even think
about it so I to say that it's just an
exorcist like parody or reap or ripoff I
just don't think that that lands there's
too much character work I love the idea
in that I'd say the execution of the
she's in the chair the chair spins
around and said any other I feel like
I've seen that it's been done that's not
only bad we want to talk about execution
falling short then let's get back to it
follows there's nothing in it follows
that is executed exceptionally exact for
the first scare which they get right out
of the way which is the body bent in
half right so if we're gonna talk about
executing scares I don't think it
follows as the place we need to point to
I don't know I think the hallway bedroom
scene when the guy the 8-foot tall
gigantic man walks into the bedroom my
audience don't scare me I'm not trained
to piss on it's a good movie I don't
even think it's the best zombie movie in
the 21st century let alone the best
trained movie that goes to snowpiercer
or Tony Scott's unstoppable about that
no I mean I think that you know again
the whole idea was traded was not and
the thing that really spoke to me was
the fact that you know even even
revisiting it in terms of getting pretty
prepared to do this fight today there is
this it's what I keep coming back to is
the fact that you've got some really
good again character work in there and
you have that final scene and I
literally started crying again just
thinking about it because you come to
the final scene where we're all of
humanity is falling apart as far as we
know there are no survivors anywhere and
we see that final moment where you have
the pregnant wife and the daughter who
are walking into Busan and there are
people there that are about to shoot
them and then it circles back to this
whole thing and the reason that they
don't end up shoot of is because they
hear the little girl
singing and she's finally able to
execute this song that she wanted to
sing for her father who she finally
connected with even though he ended up
becoming a zombie and these are a lot of
spoilers for this film actually I would
say that that train to Busan is an
excellent film and I actually agree with
a lot of your points Emma but I think
the problem for me with trained of your
son is twofold the first one is I didn't
of as far as scares go like the question
is what makes the best or a great horror
movie and I think in addition to makeup
effects and tropes whether it is
something following you whether it is
the zombie whether it is demonic
possession or ghosts you have to have
bring something new to the table to move
that for our Danny Boyle did it with 28
days later right the rage virus by
making them fast summaries but for me
train up a son there's not an iconic
there's iconic character moment sure
there's not a conics can see it I think
for me it would be when they figure out
the whole thing that basically if the
zombies can't see you they can't come
after you and it's the creative use that
they use of every time they go through
the tunnels in order to advance up a
train car to try to get to the survivors
who are in the front car that was
something that really stuck with me and
that I had not seen it executed in the
zombie genre let's shift gears everybody
Clark you're about to continue please
just roll that into your final talk oh
sure sure sure I would just say that
like with most most creatures that they
can't see you they can't hurt you so
necessarily like to me it doesn't really
close the deal but what I would say is
something like the conjuring is you know
to me it works on all levels
there are iconic scarce there you are
seeing a true masterwork of a of a great
director meaning like I would argue it
follows is a great debut sure absolutely
and similar to the conjuring semi where
Warren Terry will tell well-worn
territory trains Busan is an excellent
zombie movie but to me the conjuring
overall hits all of the important best
horror movie moments it has deep
characters great performances excellent
scares everybody remembers and you can
point to it and say wow this is
something special you also see the
progression of a director if you
from saw to dead silence to insidious
and insidious chapter 2 you have
something like the conjuring which is a
grown-up very special movie so that's
why I think it is the best horror movie
of the 21st century thanks Clark wolf
Cameron oh man my movies got a real
bitchin score I couldn't even hum you
anything from these other two movies but
that bad disasterpiece score is so good
and you might go who cares
let me tell you there's a movie called
Halloween you remember that score thirty
years later scores better and man
Michael Monroe kills it in that movie
overall I think it follows the reason it
follows is the best movie is because
it's actually trying to say something
and it's saying something subtly it's
not throwing it in your face you guys
are get it or you don't and that's the
art of filmmaking here's what happens
when society collapse and the evolution
of people and aren't you going to be a
good person and are you going to rescue
people also I part of my love a train to
Busan is just because of the fact that I
am legitimately terrified of fast
zombies so there were a lot of very very
good scares of that movie for me
personally it's very subjective and
again it's not reinventing the wheel it
is it is exemplifying this genre at its
best by really delving into the themes
that it ought to explore in a way that
Walking Dead's been unable to do over
how many since eight nine ten thousand
and also I felt very betrayed by GaN you
in this film because just a little
cultural context GaN you who plays the
main character and this is usually like
the upstanding hero and even though he
eventually gets there he's a real dick
at the beginning of this movie
boom Wow learn a lot about these scary
movies and a little bit about the art of
filmmaking Denver oh come for you
what do we got on the back to front just
a couple of things related to endless
pick I think there's a little slip of
the tongue oh it's a 2016 movie III
heard 2006 but my ears are dead I said
I'm I wrote 16 if I've said 6 then but
you all were choice also with the Busan
of course spelled Busan but then locally
its Busan Busan Pusan you see it all the
ways but I have I had from this light
source that went there that it's Pusan
no I can only go with my source sure ok
I can't use your source my integrity is
a fact-checker means that I cannot
reveal my source I appreciate that I
appreciate that but I mean those are
those are so ticky tack that I almost
feel bad that I have to do this job how
oh sure but you know but yours you know
no fact will pass you by it will catch
all the facts and that I'm not not
material to the arguments themselves
which I thought were out well done all
around absolutely
ok so um I agree that the arguments were
well done all around and we there were
there were points made and then there
were counter points and there were
points there were attacks on each
other's films that some landed some were
parried I thought we we hit
Cameron's choice of it follows with some
strong arguments that you weren't as
invested in the characters that it was a
little bit of a divisive film and we
didn't have you know a great comeback
for that even though he laid out some
strong things to love about it follows
and I know I fall closer to your opinion
on it but at the end of the day there
was some good attacks on your choice so
it came down to Emma and Clarke for me
and man that not adding anything to the
genre and then I think Cameron had some
good attacks as far as it not being
either the best zombie or train movie
when you think of like who used the
medium better it was it snowpiercer was
it train to Busan take pause but I felt
Clark defended against attacks well and
she laid out so many thumb attic
elements and so many things to love
about the movie
aside from something I really just took
I personally disagree calling James Wan
the next Spielberg
we should talk about this next time any
time yeah overall I felt Clark made a
great case for the conjuring and I'm
going Clark Wolfe Dan Veronica yeah this
is a very very difficult decision for me
like I said everybody had such good
arguments and for me in the end it came
down to Clark and I really respect the
Cameron's choice but I think his
arguments are more around certain
elements of the film that worked well as
as opposed to the the film as a whole
yeah and I just felt that the more
well-rounded argument as far as
addressing multiple element of the film
was Clark's so I I'm with you how I
would also go with Clark Wolfe really
the only one I want to do it
we really because it's a horror
halloween themed episode can I say the
point goes to Clark werewolf yes what
does the pole have been saying what are
the people saying on line on line B
poles have it follows at 26% train to
Busan at 25 percent and the conjuring at
48 percent
I did see a really interesting point for
train to Busan which was out of the
three choices the conjuring is
phenomenal but train to Busan took a
sour stale zombie genre and flipped it
and that is at TJX did anyone have any
other strong choices or contenders they
thought should have been in the mix they
saw the most forget out in the which is
a genre twisty one because that's like
you know if you're arguing Best Western
oh does Blazing Saddles right yeah
something like that
but there's a great choice and the witch
that's sort of like a little gem that I
don't think a lot of people have seen it
also devices it's kind of Indian follows
camp of like people either really love
it or they hate it my second choice was
the babadook stuff you guys so Clark is
a head one-nil 2-nil going into question
numero dos and here you go question or
two what is the coolest horror movie
death of all time like what's the death
really like whoa that was a coolest like
of all time though yeah yeah question
number two let's start player number two
Cameron Rice I'm going with the
marionette death from night Brando
Street part three the dream
this is the bag the reason it's the
coolest dance that I'm sure we can't
show photo the reason is the cool is
dead is this the Deaf a good death in a
horror movie something that sticks with
you a cool death is a one that also
pushes some stuff forward and what I
love about that death and I'm right now
Street part 3 is up to this point Freddy
is stabbing people or invisibly throwing
girls across the room this is the death
that went this is what the nightmare
series can be and from there that's
where we get pizza death that's where
you get wizard death that's where you
get Freddy Krueger in a comic book that
one's not really good but outside of
that it's the marionette theft that
kicks it off and it's the depth that a
lot of people talk about it they talk
about the nightmare series a lot of
people they might not remember what film
it's from exactly which one they might
not even remember who the character was
that had had happened to but if they
talk about the marionettes their death
they're like oh the one with the veins
the veins look it's a death that gets
under your skin and that's why it's the
coolest
oh yeah coming strong with the pawns all
right what do you think suppose I'm in
the same franchise it's cam and I'm
taking it back to the og sticks with you
Nightmare on Elm Street death which is
the death of Glen who is played by
Johnny Depp in the first Nightmare on
Elm Street up to this point in the film
he has basically been the useless
boyfriend character he falls asleep and
unfortunately is killed by his
television set at which point he gets
sucked down into his bed in what we
didn't see there is his entrails all get
spit back up out of the void that was
his bed and then there's blood raining
down from the ceiling and down into the
living room below again it is it was a
big moment within the nightmare series
again this happens in the first film up
to this point we've seen a girl being
thrown around and visibly we've seen her
boyfriend gets strangled in the middle
of the night when he is in prison but we
haven't seen Freddy just really get in
there and rip somebody to shreds and
you'll eat in you're left with this
impression of just this geyser of blood
coming out of a bed and this is also the
first time where we've like really seen
Freddy kill somebody with them not even
having a moment to defend themselves so
it really elevates that level of now
we're super afraid of what this guy can
do because previously you know people
had seen him we don't really see what
happens to the boyfriend but besides him
getting strangled but again that's a
pretty typical death we saw the
girlfriend teen I have a chance to fight
back but now Freddy means business and
there's nothing you can do you are just
going to end up as a puddle of blood all
over your parents house right on okay
taking it back to the og nightmare
that's like even pre Jackie Earle Haley
Clark werewolf all right these were
great horror movie next and I feel like
as a horror fan I often have to explain
myself like Oh like how can you watch
all this I just watch people get mess is
there something wrong with you are you
dare you detached from reality and
oftentimes I've seen no there is art
there is such great things here to be
seen in and these are two beautifully
artistic and gutting and scary horror
movie deaths but that wasn't the
question the question is what is the
coolest horror movie death and my
friends there is only one answer
it's Samuel Jackson and deep blue sea
really upsetting and this one really
checks the boxes it's scary
it comes out of nowhere nobody saw that
coming and it has endured over in the
vein of psycho killing your big movie
star right who's gonna kill samuel
l.jackson in the first 20 minutes all
right fight it out y'all so let's go
about the definition of cool we're gonna
say Samuel Jackson's death of Debussy is
cool the way assault bei me miss cool
what I don't even know what that means
what assault what salt bay salt bass oh
man you know
yeah should get you get some great salt
in the meat that meaning that we
it's an internet meme of all variates
internet meme of all dank memes around
all that cool to me and it's basically
this is this is on the level of the Jon
Voight death and anaconda where it Sam
Jackson is dead he then there's no
what's amazing is with something like
deep blue sea which by the way I can our
iron here your arguments because because
you guys would be wrong what I will say
is you're right it's great when Samuel
Jackson is there and then the last 80%
of it when it becomes a CGI man you know
what just just to like go along the in
terms of the actual death itself being
called I agree that the moment is
extremely cool and deeply saying
obviously made a huge impact I mean
because as you say it's like I thought
we were homies here and that I was
betrayed but ultimately it's Sam Jackson
getting eaten by a CGI shark niche is
and you compared it to psycho so why
wouldn't you fix I don't explain it's
like the moment is absolutely cool but
the death itself I think is fairly
mundane if I may the fact that this
genetically modified sharks leap out of
the air and has and we established that
this shark has brain function and is
able to
let's talk about Freddy Krueger yeah
let's talk about some of these deaths
okay Emma I actually have to disagree
with you on on Glen's death being I
don't think Glen's death is even the
coolest in the first Friday
I actually think Tina and the rotating
room is probably I would think I mean I
think most horror fans would argue that
that one is actually the coolest death
of even that one of the first Freddy
Krueger would be debated Glen dies off
screen his body dies off screen like
dream warriors go you know look I with
horror movies you always have to get
into franchise fatigue right it's a
thing that happens I think you know with
fans and with like you know it's it's
kind of a tricky thing because like
because you're you have to like raise
and raise the you know raise the stakes
and raise the stakes and raise the
stakes and at this point like you said
it kind of in that moment officially
betrayed like the Fruitvale legacy that
was established by the first one and
kind of made me meaning I mean that's
the criticism of Freddy Krueger is that
franchise goes he becomes a clown
whereas in the first film he's actually
a threat and so him kind of being a
literal puppet master I think it
devalues Freddy scariness I think it
changes things up I don't know if it D
values him I would say I think the fact
that the whole scene starts off as the
with a stop-motion creepy stop motion
animation Freddy which looked real dope
but it still looks real cool and some
people might be like that looks lame I
guarantee you're gonna tell me number
but workers business your favorite
movies get back out of here at least
stop motion is the bomb
so you have that but I definitely don't
believe in four treys the franchise if
anything it's up the franchise's ante
part four is where it gets and we're not
picking nothing from our four part four
is where it gets a little bit goofy
that's where he becomes a little too
punny becomes a little too silly he's
wearing sunglasses is on the beach he's
in the daytime no ways you want to see
Freddy in this it's a creepy mental
hospital he's using the marionette
people and if the idea is it's betraying
the first two films because he's changed
the way he's doing things then we got to
throw out every superhero movie past
part one because they're constantly
changing things and moving things
forward and changing the series and with
Cameron go ahead and give us your final
thoughts a cool death is about
legitimacy being legitimately cool cool
is not trying too hard and a nightmare
now is three part three it's a simple
thing of taking a children's idea of a
marionette using your veins and killing
it's very simple it's all fun and that's
what makes that death very cool is that
it's effortless all right Thank You
Cameron Rice and the vibe you want to
talk about cool and effortless and
turning something on its head we've got
a kid being killed by his television set
literally being sucked into his bed
ripped into shreds spit out as entrails
and ultimately you don't even see the
killer do it that's how cool and
effortless it truly is and also it's
Johnny Depp so there's that all right
Thank You Feist background to Wolfe give
us your final thoughts all right well
once again as a horror fan you know
watching people die cool is hard to say
right but I would already get the
problem with these other two examples is
that they're they are very artistic and
I don't not that they can't be mutually
exclusive but I feel like when we're
talking about cool those two deaths err
on the side of art whereas I mean what
is cooler than samuel l.jackson nothing
nothing is cooler than samuel l.jackson
and in terms of the moment and in terms
of moments that will live forever in the
minds of horror fans and non horror fans
alike I don't know if you get cooler
than the coolest person ever getting
eaten by a shark when he is on land and
everyone thinks he's safe
alright time cool death school horror
movie deaths Dan Merle take us to the
fact zone there's a couple things Samuel
Jackson was killed one hour and 47
minutes in the cycle I'm kind of
colloquially was saying like oh they
killed her off 20 minutes and it's
actually closer to 45 but you know the
point being that you take out your main
star of wait earlier than perhaps it was
anticipated this rain tend to get
shortened over time correct oh yeah
that's right maybe yeah the Jon Voight
clip referenced is from the masterpiece
anaconda where he's eaten by an anaconda
then later vomited up manages to get a
wink off before he's eaten the second
time snake Dan please tell us your
thoughts on the round oh wow I'm up
first these are really three good picks
for the deaths this one wasn't Clarke
and Cameron for me going by the coolest
metric and whose soul is like the
coolest death and I think I think by a
narrow margin I think Clark's told me a
little bit more on hers so I'd have to
go with Clark right on yeah this was
yeah three three bloody fun and yeah
Clark I appreciate you taking us into
the mindset of you don't have to be a
murderer
thanks and I liked I got you were
starting to really sell me when you're
um talking about how cool samuel
l.jackson is and I had a flashback in my
mind to him talking about everybody in
the restaurant and Pulp Fiction be a
bunch of little Fonzie's and stay cool
so there's a great moment so four and
then uh Emma you uh you were painting a
great picture with yours and I was just
I was just thinking about with all the
blood splashing out I just think about
how much Johnny Depp loves red wine but
by a very narrow margin I think
everybody because Cameron had such a
great opening salvo when he talked about
how that death just really set the tone
of so much we were a member about
nightmare and it was just this turn in
the franchise that was iconic and Freddy
Krueger it's just like it was clay off
him marionette and that guy
I feel like throughout the rest of the
round Clark and Emma like we're just
nipping at your heels and but that
opening salvo was more or less
unbeatable to me so Cameron you took it
in my mind source tied up one one we're
going to the hole to decide Vanessa what
do we got so on the polls we have the
marionette death at 28 percent the
Johnny Depp Nightmare on Elm Street
death at 36 percent and Sam Jackson at
34 percent
add 36 all right that means Vanessa we
are going to your personal opinion
tiebreak Vanessa [ __ ] welcome to the
facts as much as I love the shark death
scene I know sharks can jump jumping you
know it was a credit to all of your
choices you have your arguments that you
each got a vote that round so nicely
done Cameron you take it by a hair Thank
You Vanessa all right so we're going
into question number three and we are
tied 1-1 Emma
looking to get on the board Emma looking
to get on the board here question number
three oh my goodness questions oh my
goodness is question cut to dance shirt
Dan let's see that shirt I think you're
the three of us perhaps between the two
of us why I'm wired how I take off my
mic
here is the question what slasher would
win in a battle royale ma'am and we got
three great choices maybe the three best
choices if you read our series all the
choices so excited about this question
okay like you couldn't have a horror
episode without this question I'm a bite
all right lay it down I am ready to cast
my vote for house shirt I am arguing on
behalf of Michael Myers aka the shape
from Halloween now the thing is is in
addition to Michael Myers being one of
the og slashers who definitely helped
launch the genre of dead teenager movies
that we saw in the 1980s as my mom likes
to lovingly refer to them as is truly
the embodiment of evil that is all that
he is he is a supernatural force a force
of nature an evil force loose a force
that is unkillable and that is according
of course to John Carpenter but the
thing that makes the shape so imposing
as a as a slasher figure and as a
murderer is the fact that he really just
keeps coming it's like I talked earlier
about my my massive fear of fast zombies
he invokes the same kind of fear that
slow zombies do which is that you can
knock him down as much as you want but
they are just gonna keep getting back up
and coming after you and he might not
necessarily be fast but he's not dumb
either and he is willing to use whatever
resources are available him to kill
people and ultimately his motivation is
that he just likes killing people right
on Michael Myers background at Clarke
wolf who you got I mean my two fellow
competitors made the argument for me
said that Freddy Krueger gave us the
greatest movie deaths ever and great
arguments very compelling in addition to
the fact that my other competitors
argued this Ruby so well add that we
actually kind of know the answer to this
question if any of you have seen the
masterpiece depicted on mr. damerov
seizure
you know spoiler alert that Freddy
actually ends up winning in the end at
the end of the day Freddy Krueger is a
masked the mastermind right he is he is
the he's a thinker and he's conniving
and he's tricky and a puppet master if
you will so my choice is gonna have to
be Freddy Krueger okay and for the
record we are going on the arguments
made in this round alone good points
there Clark Thank You Cameron who you
got I gotta pull a move like a certain
man named LeBron James let me tell you
about LeBron James LeBron James likes to
work with winners and as we read earlier
this week Friday the 13th is accurate
and so LeBron is stripped off one
jerseys I have
putting on a hockey mask on top of that
let me also go through real quick some
stats we don't have the new Halloween on
here yet but as far as victims go jason
has a whopping 150 eight victims i'm my
mans jason voorhees by the way I might
not have said earlier so Jason he's got
the body count the other thing about
Jason Hsu is it's not just that he's a
zombie and it's not just that he's thick
he's a thick zombie that's fast and
seemingly can't be killed some of the
movies they don't even kill him they
just put a chain around his neck and
dump them in the river hoping somebody
else will deal with it later the number
of times Jason has not died phenomenal
they dumped his ass in toxic waste
and that's why I'm taking Jason Voorhees
and I'll get into why he's the correct
option yeah as we go on listen yes
canonically speaking especially because
this latest Halloween film erased all of
the other ones that existed got the
lowest body count of any of these guys
however he's also the wild card because
he's the one that's not in Freddy vs.
Jason so he is the one that has the most
opportunity to really surprise us and on
top of that as I say he is somebody that
has no emotional investment whatsoever
in what he is doing Freddy and Jason
both do they both have mommy issues okay
both have very emotional strained
relationships with their moms Mike Myers
just like killed his sister and was like
that's cool I'm gonna keep killing
people that's our accounting the new
film and your argument cuz he spent 40
years in prison
contained like that very all any of our
fighters they try to approach him with
the shackles it's like a low bastard I'm
telling you she is a wild card okay if
you'd actually gone up to him in that
prison I think he would have started
some [ __ ] and on top of that he's had
all these years in prison to just sit
can kill people and he doesn't even need
to think about it because ultimately
he's resourceful he'll be walking by him
he's like cool
telephone wire we don't have this
anymore but they sure did in the 70s let
me just strangle you with that real fast
Oh catch a knife that looks cool how
about a shovel like again he is this
this force that is always just pushing
forward that has no motivation other
than the fact that he likes to kill
people
both Freddy and Jason again there is an
emotional investment and if Freddy wants
to get revenge on the children of the
parents that murdered him and Jason is a
whole mess of a whole mess of mommy he's
a whole mess and he's got a whole lot
going on for him and in that regard
because I agree with you Michael has
many stabbing things and we're counting
all the films in Concannon for the most
part his choices of killing people are
stabbing them or crushing their heads my
man Jason has used the harpoon gun he's
great distance is Michael Myers is very
effective and is calling up people you
don't have to get as crazy alright she's
a ginger showing honey let us not forget
that jason has been historically country
he's controllable they're controlled him
he controlled him really so the question
is who would win in a trifecta Battle
Royale that's the question right at the
end of the day if Jason is so easily
controlled then I think it just counts
him out so Michael can't even come to
the fight because here's the counter
events against Freddy and Freddy has
said both in the original film and in
Freddy vs. Jason the last time we saw
him so it continues throughout the
Gannet I need them to believe Jason dumb
as hell he ain't believing in no damn
Freddy he believed it in mom and killing
people at camp so as long as it's just
Jason and Michael Freddy ain't even
gonna be at the party well I mean like
taking that into it or not Michael again
going back to the whole idea of people
being able to katroo Michael Myers we
just find it on top of that we've seen
in the new Halloween film his ability to
have this incredible effect on people's
psyche by simply existing he doesn't
have to do anything but be this evil
killer and the doctor gets so obsessed
with him that he wants to become him no
I mean he is like the deranged murderer
man Michael isn't always head crusher
there's no doubt about it but we've seen
in in Jason Takes Manhattan
powerful people the boxer dumpster goes
now as far as G as far as Freddy if he's
pulled out of the dreamworld and we've
seen it we're not even talking about
Freddy vs. Jason we're talking about
normal movie if he's pulled out of the
movie a 15 year old girl or boy deals
with him perfectly fine he's gonna go
you know other human people this is a
conversation about these three slashers
and LeBron at the end of the day LeBron
James would kick all these guys asses I
don't think that you can come back from
the fact that you know Freddy Freddy has
puppet master Jason many many times and
yeah well lots of times during Freddy
vs. Jason I've depicted a Morel shirt
but and and jason is controllable and at
the end of the day
Michael milder Michael Myers can be
contained by pure Sheila's is your final
thought which means that he would by the
way also gave gift we can do I know he's
pure evil and he's the shape but also
can we kill him what can he go to jail
it doesn't have a physical body
I'm confused too much confusion Michael
Myers is too close to being a human
being therefore that leaves Jason
Voorhees and at the end of the day Jason
Voorhees is all muscle no brains he does
what he's told and ready is crafty and
smart also Freddy wins afraid first
Jason so we this has already settled law
Cameron I would debate if winning is
having her decapitated head wink at the
camera
but john-boy did not win against that
anaconda going back to the stats for a
minute Freddy Krueger has 43 kills
that's an impressive number for you and
me but against Michael Myers or Jason's
that's pretty low because Freddy is
Freddy's a bit of an artist he really
has to think out his deaths so if he
suddenly got two of them people he's got
to deal with that Freddy's the terrence
malick of killers cc's tickets to live
between projects and so he's just not
gonna know how to handle two other guys
who are just left and right ripping him
apart he's chewing his head he's gotta
get that first raft out of the way all
right Thank You Cameron I'm throwing my
hat in for the wild-card here first
Jason so we really don't know and the
answer is that he would beat both of
them anyway because again at the end of
the day you want to talk about sheer
willpower that just simply will not be
taken down by any of these other killers
who are all out there getting super
creative like like Freddy is or like
Jason trying to punch people's heads
that's not gonna happen cuz even if he
punches are off that bridge he's just
gonna fall he's gonna look over that
bridge and then where did Michael Myers
go Julie Kurtz Goethe said huh what a
delightful throwdown
you painted some grisly pictures in my
mind Dan Morelle where are we factually
actually a John Carpenter didn't call
indeed call Michael Myers unkillable
back when Halloween h2o was released but
Clarke will play your alien touched on a
third rail and I will put myself in this
and the horror community yes is the
eternal question Jason Wright if you
asked me I would say that Jason one says
that Freddy one now this debate is
ongoing to this day because yeah Jason
is carrying Freddy's severed head how
did he doesn't her so just like to point
out that in the Freddy verse on Mays
that was at Universal Studios Hollywood
years ago Wow I would just dispute the I
would dispute though be has been for 15
years and will continue to be trying to
deport a horror fan public opinion okay
so I love this this Throwdown Dan thank
you for calling that out I think that's
important because yeah it is it is not
completely decisive there so many great
quotes in this round by the way I love
that your mom calls them dead teenager
say what up to mrs. fight for me I love
that you compared Freddie to terrence
malick
killing his history of life which is
this thin red line in red bloody line
but yeah and you guys have great
arguments like Clarke you were coming
with so much passion for Freddie I loved
it and this is a really difficult choice
I loved everything I heard but you know
at the end of the day Cameron had so
many specifics and that just really
started to win me over he came in with
the body count he came in with the
weapons and that cut through a lot of
the chatter and in just a neck and neck
and neck
decapitation all around brace I go
Cameron with Jason by a hair damn this
was very well fought on everyone's side
everyone approached it differently I
will say I had to knock Emma out because
I felt like she was sorta teamed up on
poor Michael Myers yeah his mortality
his vulnerability his potential
unavailability
again to meet come down to Freddy vs.
Jason my own thoughts of it outside of
it and just go by the arguments and I
thought that Clark had a good argument
about the fact that Jason is very
controllable we did see that but where
Emma did play into this fight was
regardless of what happens to Michael
Myers I liked the idea or the argument
the Cameron made that Freddy is very
much a mastermind he will get
overwhelmed he meets he puts a lot of
thought into this and he's going to be
fielding a lot of different things
whether or not Michael Myers survives to
the end I like the idea that Freddy
might be multitasking a little bit too
much I was on Freddy train and also
through but Cameron won me over Deanna I
gotta go with Cameron
true story I am sorry Jason takes it
Jason
would be five minutes of us sitting in
the studio in the last 10 minutes is
just the movie nice some commentary on
the Friday the 13th nicely done Vanessa
what done the poll have to say I will
say before I announce the poll Twitter
loved Jason listen we got the polls came
to 26% for Michael Myers 28% for Jason
and 45% for Freddie
Clark it's a tiny victory the internet
agrees so are there any other choices I
mean these are three icons but did
anyone say what about this one
I did see two for Leatherface and cocky
a little Chuckie join in the fun
said pinhead well he'll raise action all
right for sure but it's fine
a little too much fun everybody I'm just
kidding
so um after three rounds everybody it is
two for camera and one for Clarke Emma
you fought valiantly and like you had an
awesome answer yeah yeah all about that
Fife life so I'll probably come to you
just for some thoughts as we're entering
into the speed round here we go we are
entering the speed round it is two for
Cameron one for Clarke first player to
four points wins and Vanessa will be
coming to you for your opinions this
this round to help us decide all right
and again how speed run worse I'll ask
the question chime in with your answers
first person to answer you will
elaborate on your answer first you'll
get twenty seconds and the next player
gets twenty seconds and then ten second
rebuttal ten second rebuttal here we go
what horror villain should get a
spin-off where he or she is the hero
Ammar don't you get spin-off where he or
she is a hero
evil ashram are a darkness evil ash from
army of darkness sorry I'm trying to go
faster but this is I don't know I don't
wanna forfeit wait wait okay I will say
regen possessed regen I wasn't Regan
MacNeil from the exercise yes Regan
MacNeil friend The Exorcist all right so
we have evil ash from army of darkness
Regan MacNeil from The Exorcist Camryn
smoke first so Camryn 20 seconds began
whenever you speak now we've already
seen this kind of story happened before
it was called the Scorpion King Scorpion
King was the villain and The Mummy
Returns came back had a trilogy of films
you do that with evil ash you make him
the hero of this evil Camelot with
zombies he learns his ways oh my God
he's got to continue he's got to be the
king hail to the king baby it's evil ash
as real ash lives on in the modern world
evil ash controls the Deadites and it's
a very Camelot II story okay Thank You
Clark 20 seconds begin when you speak at
the end of the day like we've already
said with horror movies they're all
about what's going on underneath and I
think seeing a little girl who survived
trauma in her childhood grow up and
actually be able to maybe work with
other traumatized kids while still
fighting off the evil that might still
live inside her as a truck or more
formally traumatized child child is it
would be scary but also heartfelt 10
second rebuttal kick doesn't necessarily
sound like spin-off sounds like it's
just the Exorcist 3 I've never heard of
a spin-off where the main character is
the main character in the spin-off from
the original film at least evil ash is
not ash and so at least you have
something different happening there you
could argue that key or a Karras or or
Merrin are the main characters and Regan
is not in Exorcist 3 and you compared
yours to the Scorpion King so my work is
done
okay so make number three tell us your
thoughts on this battle who do you think
took it someone brought up a really
interesting point that Reagan isn't the
villain Pazuzu is so I'm gonna give it
to camera just cuz I really like the
universe that you created for evil ash
like I want it I want to see more of
what that landscape looks like all right
that's one for Cameron Dan Merle I was
going down that road a little bit but
then Clark brought into her argument
that she would still be battling the
evil that's inside of her so that to me
said that you know she would not just be
a normal person she would still have
this evil inside of her and then I think
the carrots to Argus are a little
counter to each other cuz he said in his
argument that evil ash would just live
on as ash from the Evil Dead but then
she said then he said that Clark's
answer was invalid because it's just the
character living on is the character
from the first movie I think those two
can flick with each other so I'm gonna
give the point to Clark I think her
arguments one all right so it's one one
yeah the these are both strong choices
but I liked to what Vanessa was saying I
like the world that Cameron set up a
little more
Clark's world like she said that Regan
be working with traumatized kids I'm
like what is just like a movie about
kids with possession problems at a
counseling side oh no I can't quite see
it as much so I go Cameron with this and
it is three to one so this is game point
Clark you need this to keep her going
alright okay alright here we do a
question question number two with a
speed round better child performance
Linda Blair in The Exorcist or hailey
Joe Osmond and The Sixth Sense Blair
okay so we got hailey from Clark we got
Linda from Cameron Clark you spoke first
20 seconds again when you speak now
alright so in addition to being a lovely
beautiful performance Haley Joel Osment
received an Oscar nomination for his
work
and I think that we see a lot of layers
with Haley and his character we see the
sadness we see the fear but we also see
this weekend he's fun and he likes to
have a good time his relationship with
Tony collects beautiful and he made
Bruce Willis a better actor it's easy to
dismiss Linda Blair because of the work
after the Exorcist wasn't as good but
that's cuz The Exorcist is so good that
it was a marker you get to see both
sides of Regan good to see Regan as a
normal girl with her mom and then you
get to see what happens when she's
possessed to traumatization her in the
hospital
as much as English Osmond kills it in
that role you kind of see him in that
one beat of already being traumatized we
get to know who Regan is before the
trauma happens to Regan it's actually
heavily disputed who did more of the
performing in the Exorcist Regan or I'm
sorry Linda Blair or her stunt double so
I don't think that you can actually make
that argument accurate where is Haley
Joel Osment and did it all I gotta go by
the language of the movie the language
of the movie says Linda Blair was the
star of that film or at least played
Regan throughout the entire picture just
exquisitely laid out in her opening
argument why I'm Haley Joel Osment gave
the better performance Michael Clark on
this one Vanessa I'm getting it to Clark
as well like hailey Joe Osmond had to
stand up to a Bruce Willis performance
and came out as the highlight that's if
I'm an idol right on absolutely am i any
other thoughts on this yeah I'm my
inclination would have been to go with
Haley Joel Osment myself and I think
that Clark painted the picture extremely
well that entire movie was just hinged
on the fact that you really believed
that this kid saw ghosts yeah so
absolutely like like you were painting
that some of the different flavors we
saw from hailey Joe Osmond and I was
like oh okay so it's three - it is three
- going into question number three of
the speed round oh can you direct your
sights to the screenplay is this a
bargain bin question are each one of
these movies do you buy here we go call
out your answer which one do you buy
Cameron you have an eight-legged freak
sir
JT thank you for putting that up there
brother okay so Clark would slither
Cameron with eight legged freaks Clark
you spoke first so 20 seconds again when
you speak now okay well objectively slow
there is a better movie but on top of
that you are seeing James Gunn finally
get behind the camera of a horror movie
with a budget this cast is incredible
it's a great blend of horror comedy
horror comedies hard to do we've seen it
fail many times and I would argue that
slither easily pulls it off plus the
cast is fantastic you've got Elizabeth
Banks you've got Michael Rooker
alright you got a love a movie that says
what it is right out the gate there's no
surprises here hey legged freaks really
it has it shines a light on an old
pastime of 50 sci-fi films David
Arquette has maybe been better but you
know what he's really good in this too
and the movie actually has the title the
film as dialog I love something like
that that's great it's for the people
that made Independence Day and y'all
love Independence Day
I'll give it a chance okay I love a
Lincoln and not as much as the next
person
it's fun to do a throwback the problem
is that it doesn't do it well where our
slither is also a throwback to another
kind of horror film and it succeeds it
elevates that sub-genre everyone hates
spiders slugs which is we are we're
locked up at 3:00 3:00 this is the ball
game folks
this one is for all the marbles here we
go what horror movie would be the worst
to find yourself actually experiencing
firsthand 28 days later hmm
the mist okay we have the mist and 28
days later Clark spoke first 20 seconds
began when you speak now okay 28 days
later is scary because hey pandemics are
real and they could happen on top of
that you have flesh-eating or you have
the rage virus so we're talking fast
zombies if you are an in shape and you
are stuck on that island which is
England that you are in trouble they are
coming for you plus the devastation that
has taken over the city technologically
is tragic and have you ever been stuck
in a place where the dumb idiots are in
charge and it seems the most uninformed
are the people actually running things
well welcome to America and welcome to
the mist the mist is America in a little
tiny 7-eleven and you're stuck you're
stuck you have to listen to the
uninformed people they seem to be
running everything they want to kill
your boy because that's the thing that
their thing they have to do and then
there's monsters outside I'm sorry but
spoilers for the mist if you just hide
in the right place the army is gonna
come and save you so there is actually
an answer to the problem in the mist
whereas 28 days later as we see in 28
weeks later it gets worse don't mic drop
now you don't know what happened it
might come back
what do you days later we know why whoa
all right 28 days later the mists I
don't wanna be travel either
Vanessa what are your thoughts I think
the 28 weeks later argument sold it for
Clark for me I think while the Miss did
have a solution and resolution we really
have that for 28 days later just feels
like an infinite dare yeah
alright so you're gonna Clark Clark
great Danna Clark sold me on the
multi-faceted horror of her situation
and also the solution the potential to
to Cameron's situation Cameron did not
have I think Clark had there so based on
both of those things I am also gonna go
you know plus of your trapping to
7-eleven you get all those two this was
crazy good today you guys so much fun
Clark come on get some shoutouts whatnot
yes well you can find me on the internet
in various places including DC Universe
but you can find me on instagram at
Clark Wolfe Clark with an e wolf with an
e right on and are you dressing up for
anything as for Halloween
oh I sure AM alright but let's say it's
vintage a giant record
[Applause]
a VCR awesome awesome work today and
just super fun to just like listen to
all you guys Thank You Clark
Cameron Rice well played this nicely
done you took it to the limit calm / to
Rasik alien I also if you like the
horror stuff IgM a [ __ ] RPG over at
hyper RPG every Tuesday night and also
go check out my photography Instagram
its cameras photo where you can see Emma
as Freddy Krueger I just put some of
those up so go check out those ones some
Halloween costume I wanna share
oh yeah we're doing a Super Mario
Brothers group so yeah I'm dressing up
as Koopa from the movie so great today
please give us some plugs cetera yeah I
mean you know I got lots of good stuff
going on in the Schmo down along with
Clark wolf who is part of my faction the
5 club debatably the best section in the
entire row down I don't know if that's
debatable yeah yeah cuz you guys are the
current team champions so you know
there's that also right now I am on a
short horror series over at hyper RPG as
well that is GM di Joestar I think he
left it dead it is a Call of Cthulhu
campaign we're doing it on Wednesday
nights at 7 o'clock p.m. we've done the
first two volumes last night was volume
2 so you plenty of time to catch up and
now volume 3 will happen next week on
Halloween I will not be in my halloween
costume then cuz we've got another funky
thing happening after that where we have
to be characters from clue but for
actual and my Halloween costume for this
Super Mario Brothers group are doing is
I I'm going to be Wario yesö villain but
also maybe an antihero and yeah I got
felt to make myself a mustache it's
gonna be great
very cool thank you I'm a 5 Dan burro
what's going on brother costumes this
weekend oh yeah I got something cooked
up no spoilers or spoilers right on it's
fun it's a fun one I have no doubt I
have no doubt Dan yeah I might see you
this weekend right we've got a right
that sounds weird yes
thanks Vanessa grin thank you so much
[Applause]
yeah thank you so much for holding it
down are you dressing up oh yeah any big
plans wrong oh yeah I'm gonna be the day
man from it's always sunny and my
boyfriend's gonna be the night man nice
very cool and any anything you want plug
or shout out just if you check me on
Twitter on at Ness curtain and I have a
podcast called bruja and check it out
hey yes I will let you know that I'm
gonna be dressing up with my fiance
we're gonna do an 80s movie reference
from fatal attraction she's going to be
Glenn Close and I will be the bunny
lecture and I'm very excited about it
that I want to thank all of our fighters
I want to thank Dan and Vanessa Billy
jte and thanks again to gamestop for
sponsoring this episode don't forget you
can find these halloween shirts and
plenty of fun cool merch over there and
please give me a follow at Hal Rudnick
on Twitter on Instagram
Perceval will be there first of all the
owl
just just follow me and say hi to
Percival thanks for watching everybody
we'll see you next week bye bye oh
thanks billion titi